this is a production of Cornell
University
okay all right there are no
announcements let's get started my
name's Adam Bogdanov I'm the doctoral
adviser of today's seminar speaker it's
my great pleasure to introduce her
morgan Carter morgan is a native of
North Carolina she came to Cornell after
earning her bachelor's degree from NC
State and that was in biochemistry with
minors in genetics and biotechnology as
an undergraduate Morgan was active in
research as you might have guessed and
while and Margaret Dobbs lab at NC State
she contributed to the discovery that
poly Kinta polyketide synthesis is
associated with sexual reproduction in
pseudo circus preferences which is the
fungus that causes the devastating
disease of banana called black sigatoka
disease on admission to Cornell Morgan
was awarded two presidential life
sciences fellowship which allowed her to
do rotations and I was very fortunate
that she chose my lab for one of our
three rotations and more fortunate I
think that she was drawn to a particular
project we had ongoing at the time to
identify and characterize effector
proteins of the barley powdery mildew
pathogen using bacterial deliver of
those candidate effectors
so as morgan will describe to today
while gearing up for the sort of the
next stage in that project her attempts
to reproduce some data we had just
published before she joined the lab led
to the realization that those published
experiments were flawed they had been
confounded by an effect of bacterial
titer that we hadn't accounted for
so we retracted the paper and morgan
published her first paper then from
cornell which was a letter to the editor
explaining her findings and showing the
world basically how to do factual
delivery assays correctly so morgan
having established that bacterial
delivery assay for barley that led to it
next to a very productive collaboration
with roger anissa's lab at indiana
university and roger wises lab at Iowa
State and this study identified well it
leveraged discoveries by the in his lab
in the model plant in Arabidopsis to
identify and characterize a new and
potentially engineer able source of
resistance in barley and it wheat that
work led to her second paper published
in NP MI and that was co first authored
with Matt Helm from Roger anuses lab and
that's something she'll also tell you
about today so I guess by this time
Morgan had acquired an affinity for
translating knowledge for model systems
to discovery in non model and often
really challenging systems and so we
were fortunate again that she sort of
took the reins on a project that had
been stymieing many of us up to that
point a new project to figure out what
Tala factor like proteins in a bacterial
endosymbiotic
of an agriculturally important fungus
might be doing and this has been a
collaboration with Teresa Palacios lab
and led to Morgan's third paper which we
just heard yesterday it's okay to say
this Morgan yeah has been accepted at
PNAS when a pending minor revision so
that's really good news and if I top
suck top stop talking soon enough Morgan
will be able to tell you that story as
well just one more thing though Morgan
is not only a terrific scientist she's
shown tremendous leadership as a
graduate student I just wanted to to
share that with you here and recognize
her for that as president of the
Graduate Student Association for pp BMB
she successfully advocated for student
representation on faculty search
committees she served as our first
graduate student rep in that capacity
and now it's not
that's our regular practice now she also
helped create the sips wide the school
wide Graduate Student Association she's
advocated for sound science policy as a
member of the APS public policy board
she's been on the hill a number of times
in that capacity she regularly interacts
with students around the country through
Skype a scientists interviews if you
guys haven't done Skype a scientist
Morgan could tell you all about that
it's really rewarding she's a great
mentor to over undergraduate mentees
have been co-authors on her papers and
she's also a prolific and very popular
tweeter now if you don't know at plant
path secret where have you been if you
don't follow at plant path secret you
should and I think I'll stop there and
then we'll switch screens here and hand
over to Morgan for her presentation
thank you all for coming
okay hi everybody Thank You Adam for the
introduction so welcome to my virtual
exit seminar here I'm thankful you're
joining me today if you haven't used in
before the most important thing is going
to be to just keep your microphone muted
so that you're not distracting to
anybody else so please do so and also
you're welcome to keep your video off if
that's helping your connectivity and
also a chat button that we can use at
the very end so that you can ask
questions and help us know that you want
to ask questions so with that we'll get
started so the title of my seminar today
is actually the title of my thesis which
is translating lessons from effector
biology to fungal effector screams plant
resistance mechanisms and bacterial
fungal interactions and this is a rather
broad long title with a lot of jargony
words in it but if we kind of break it
down visually my main goal has been to
take things that we already know about
plant pathogens and how bacteria
communicate with their hosts that we've
learned in model systems and take all
those lessons and put them into systems
that we don't know much about or have a
hard time studying or to be able to just
fast track discovery of entirely new
things I try to see if I can get rid of
this bar here this doesn't seem to want
to go away
so that's okay I designed my science
slide for this so first I'm going to
talk to you about effector biology just
so that we're all on the same page of
what I mean when I'm kind of saying the
word effector so bacteria and other
microbes have to interact with their
environments and they do so using a
variety of secretion systems the top
image is showing you a bunch of
different secretion systems that are
used by bacteria to move molecules from
inside of their cells out into their
environment or into hosts when we're
talking about plant pathogens especially
gram-negative bacteria plant pathogens
one of the main secretion systems we
focus on is a type 3 secretion system
and this is shown on the bottom image
and can be thought of as a molecular
syringe that moves proteins from the
inside of the bacterial cell
the bacterial cell wall through the
plant cell wall and into the plant cell
so it's able to move something that the
bacterias made directly into a host
where it can carry out some role that's
going to help out the bacterium the type
3 secretion system is important not only
for plant pathogens but also animal
pathogens and plants and ions as well so
it's been very well studied and we know
a lot about the structure of the system
as well as the different effector
proteins that are used by some of the
bacteria during plant infection if we
think about this kind of a model of how
plants infect or how pathogens infect
plants I've shown here a very simplified
diagram just to get the basics down the
model plant pathogen pseudomonas
infecting the model plant a rabid off
siciliana the first thing is that the
bacteria are going to invade the plant
and there they can be detected by
receptors that bind microbial molecular
patterns causing a pattern triggered
immunity so basically the plant is able
to detect a single bit of bacterium for
instance a piece of the flagella and
decide this is not a plant protein this
is non-self and that's going to allow
the plant to say okay sound the alarms
we've got to put up our first defense
response and this is kind of a lesser
defense response that'll stop your
general infection the bacteria then can
secrete effector proteins to shut down
the defense response and promote
infection and this allows the bacteria
to actually win because some of these
effectors are going to go in and mess
with those proteins that were mediating
pattern triggered immunity so you have
effectors actually stopping that pti the
plant can then use intracellular
proteins to detect these effectors or
their activity and trigger effector
triggered immunity this is a larger
defense response it's actually a
programmed cell death caused in a
hypersensitive reaction and this can be
visible if you infiltrate a lot of a
bacterium into a plant that's going to
cause an HR you can actually see a large
cell death a big brown spot on the plant
so all of this in this slide is very
simplified but there are tons and tons
of proteins and
signalling components going on with each
of these parts of this interaction and
these have been very well studied
especially in Mato model pathless
systems like a rabid abscess and
Pseudomonas but what if you get outside
of a model passive system or into
something that just has a lot more to
deal with for instance with fungi they
have hundreds of potential effector
candidates
compared to bacteria that are and more
in the tens some fungi are obligate bio
tropes and cannot be genetically
manipulated and we don't really know as
much about fungal secretion so it makes
it a little bit harder to study their
effectors from that angle as well so
there's a push to use what we know about
bacteria to scream fungal candidate
effectors and to do this you just need a
bacterium with a known response on your
plant of interest so in our case we were
working in barley so if you have a
bacterium that doesn't cause that
hypersensitive reaction or HR you can
give it a candidate fungal effector with
the type 3 secretion system tag so it's
able to go through the bacterial
secretion and into the host plant and
you can test candidate effectors one by
one
to see if they're doing anything in the
plant cell the test you may want to do
is try to see if they're able to cause
an HR on their own by being detected by
the plant or if they're able to suppress
HR that's being caused by the other
bacterium that can actually cause that
so we can look for effectors that are
taking the plant off we're combing the
plant down but I found out pretty
quickly that you have to be careful
which bacterium you use in that previous
study that Adam was mentioning our lab
was using a pathogen Xanthomonas
campestris Trapani to infiltrate we were
infiltrating that into barley plants now
xcr is not a barley pathogen but it does
have its own suite of effectors and
these can still cause a host response in
barley so while it might have been
delivering the fungal effector we were
interested in it was also bringing it a
whole thing a whole bunch of things with
it so I found out that you get this
weird response that can be tighter
dependent and is only in certain barley
lines and that confounded the
lots of that study leading to a
retraction and a publication of a letter
to the editor where we advocated for the
use of disarmed plant pathogens or
things that weren't pathogens at all so
that you could have a more controlled
delivery of the your fungal effector so
what we were advocating for and what we
began using is the comer Labs
development of a Pseudomonas turnigy
poly mutant and so this is an actual
plant pathogen where all of its
effectors have been removed and so it
serves as a good kind of empty syringe
for being able to give exactly what you
want to inject into the host plant so we
did this for a little bit looking at
fungal effectors that we really weren't
coming up with much as we were going
through some powdery mildew effectors so
we turned our attention to using the
same kind of a single effector study
mechanism to be able to look at plant
resistance mechanisms instead and try to
think about the ones that we already
knew about from the model client rabbie
DOCSIS and determine if those are
present and other host plants so the
mechanism that we are interested in is
how a VRP phb is detected in a rabid
abscess now a vr p ph b is an effector
protease it's secreted by Pseudomonas
bacteria and once inside of the host
cell it localizes to the plasma membrane
where it interacts with different kinase
a--'s and actually cuts them up and the
kinase is that it's interacting with our
members of a large family conserved in
all flowering plants and some members of
this family are actually involved in
powdered sugar immunity so this effector
is trying to shut down that first line
of plant immunity unfortunately for this
bacterium PBS one is also a member of
that family and it is guarded by our ps5
which is an NL r or r gene so it's
really a decoy kinase that's trying to
trap a V RP PHP because when it's
cleaved by a b RP PHP it causes our PS v
to trigger a hypersensitive reaction or
defense response now this has been very
well studied in a rabid Oxus we know all
the players and we know all the pieces
of this that
important so why are we still kind of
talking about it like what else is there
to look at well are the collaborators of
art in Roger and ices lab discovered
that you can actually modify this same
mechanism to detect other pathogens
based on their party aces so say you
want to make a plant that's resistant to
a virus like the tobacco edge virus
which makes its own protease labeled
here is Ted if you take the cut site in
PBS one that's usually targeted by a BRP
pH B and you change that to the tobacco
edge virus cut site for its protease you
can give that new decoy back to the
plant and get the same kind of
resistance response but in this case
it's triggered by the virus instead of
by our student motifs bacterium so we're
able to make a whole new resistant plant
that's now resistant to virus using
machinery that was already in the plant
this has widespread application because
there are many kinds of plant pathogens
that create and secrete protein per TA
TSA's during their infection so this is
all great but it's all been done in a
rabid abscess and a lot of the function
of this would then be in crop plants and
things we grow to eat so that leaves us
the questions of whether or not we can
deploy PDS one mediated immunity in crop
plants and would this require moving all
those proteins that are inter a bit
OPS's into other plants or are those
proteins already in other plants we just
aren't aware of them so is there
endogenous host machinery that's
mediating the same interaction so our
objective is to determine if barley
responds to eBay v RP PHP and with the
same mechanism as a rabid OPS's with the
idea that if this mechanism is there we
can then use it to engineer barley for
new resistance so this is my knowledge
recap slide that I'll keep coming back
to and help you keep track of which
proteins and which questions I'm asking
the first thing that we need to know is
whether or not barley responds to a br
PP HP at all does it have any kind of
defense response that would imply that
there are some proteins mediating and
surveying and surveilling for a br PP HP
to answer this question we can use that
Pseudomonas syringae poly Newton to
deliver a br PP HP or a br PP HBC 90s
which is a catalytically inactive mutant
of that effector that does not able to
cleave anything so this allows us to
look for barley lines that are
responding to a TRP PHP activity not
just presence we screened 150 lines and
found that 65 responded in some way and
this range from a hypersensitive
reaction with the obvious cell death all
the way down to kind of a low chlorosis
that was just a little bit of yellowing
so that's good that means that barley is
responding to a TRP PHB and that means
that there must be proteins involved
that are mediating that response so the
first protein that we're going to look
for with the idea that it might be
involved is PBS one I mentioned the PBS
one is a member of a very conserved
kinase family so we were not surprised
to find that there are 2 PBS 1 homologs
present in barley HV PBS 1-1 and 1-2 and
these are the closest to the Arab adopts
as copy when we look phylogenetically
both of these have the ABR p p HB cut
site and both of these can be cleaved by
a TRP PHP when Co expressed in plant M
so that was pretty straightforward and
simple it looks like there are PBS 1
kinases and barley that are cleaved by
AVR P PHP so it's possible that those
are involved just like in a rabid OPS's
with mediating how this interaction
works however now comes the hard part
because now we have to find our NL R or
R gene our RPS 5 finding the NL R that
is responsible for the phenotype you're
observing can be a bit like finding a
needle in a haystack because there are
hundreds of predicted encoded and a
large eanes in predicted encoded in lars
in a genome and it's not necessarily
clear from their sequence and
phylogenetic analysis of what their
function is so to narrow down where we
needed to look for a candidate we mapped
the location of the NL r using a nested
Association mapping population that was
developed by scientists at the
University of Minnesota
this population is set up is that
there's a single common parent called
Rasmussen and this is crossed with other
barley lines that are diverse genotypes
that are your other parents the progeny
from this cross is themself to create
recombinant inbred lines with assayed
snip data so each of the resulting
plants should have about half of its
genetic information from Rasmussen and
half of it from the other parent and we
have all of that genotype data we got
very lucky
and that Rasmussen is actually a
responding line for a TRP BHB
and responds with an HR so we just had
to look for the parents in the diverse
genotypes that did not respond to a TRP
PHP and assay the sub populations for
the phenotype of AVR P PHP response we
could then combine that phenotype and
genotype data computationally and the
output of that is a Manhattan plot as
shown here a peak in this plot indicates
an area in the genome that is
significantly associated with the traits
that you are looking at so in this case
we had a single peak which is where we
assume our NL our gene will be and when
we zoom in to that peak on the third
chromosome we find a variety of an alarm
candidates that are indicated as
triangles so we've now narrowed down
from hundreds of NL our genes in the
barley genome to about 10 to 20
fast-forwarding a bit through all of
those candidates I'm mostly just going
to talk about our favorite candidate
that we subsequently named a VRP phb
response 1 or PBR 1 PBR 1 quickly turned
into my favorite candidate because when
I looked at PBR 1 in the reference
genome it actually looked to be
non-functional which doesn't sound like
a positive except that the reference
genome corresponds to a barley line that
does not respond to a TRP peach beat so
I'm actually looking for a gene that
either isn't in the reference genome or
is there in a non-functional copy when I
sequence the allele of PBR one from
rasmussen that common parent that did
respond ARP bhp
I found that there is an intact gene
there that it did look like a fully NLR
it coded at that location so I had a
gene with a predicted functional copy
and a barley line that responds to a TRP
bhp and a predicted non-functional copy
and a line that does not respond to a
VAR p PHP so signs were looking good I
next look at expression and found that
PBR 1 is expressed across barley lines
that respond to a TRP beach B and is not
necessarily expressed in those that
don't also a good sign when I sequence
the alleles of 12 different barley lines
I found that PBR one allele sequences
clustered out by the phenotypes that we
were observing when we challenged the
barley with a VRP phb so this is a lot
of good like correlation with our ABA
our PHP response and our PD our one gene
information as we were going along we
decided we need to see if PBR one was
just the copy of our PS 5 that was in
barley had this been concerned as long
as barley and a rabid Oxus had been
branching apart or was this an entirely
different an alarm that had of all this
ability so we did phylogenetic analysis
of all predicted barley and allergens at
some known arab adopts a Santa Loren
genes and found that PDR one RPS five
are not direct orthologs they're quite
far apart in terms of just your general
NL our genes but interestingly we did
find that a different gene within our
peak from our genome analysis found that
gene does not differ much in sequence or
expression between rescue stem or X
despite the fact that it looked a lot
like our PS 5 so that allowed us to more
confidently focus on PBR 1 going forward
because even though it didn't look like
RPS 5 it had these specific qualities
that looked more like what we were
expecting from a causal gene so from
there we moved into functional
verification and decided to Co Express
PBR one and a TRP bhp in planta to see
if we could rebuild that response in a
different plant unfortunately when we
cloned PBR one from rasmussen which is a
PBR 1 B allele we found that it was
incredibly auto active which is
indicated
the brown on green or teal on red leaves
and the bottom image there this is a
problem because we can't really see if
PBR 1 is interacting with other proteins
and causing a cell death if it's just
causing cell death all by itself but we
thought back to the fact that different
barley lines were responding to a br PP
HP with different intensities and
decided to then clone an allele of PBR 1
from a barley line that was just a low
chlorosis responder and found that PDR
1c and allele from one of those lines
was actually less auto active and that
allowed us to do Co expression assays so
we co-expressed PBR one seat with a dr
PP HP in the model plant de cochon of
Indiana and we did see an increase in
cell death when both of those were
present that relied on a TRP PhD
activity this is analogous with what we
see when we co express our PS 5 and the
arab adaxes PDS one with a br PP HP in
the same clamp we verified this by
electrolyte leakage assay but you might
be noticing that I'm kind of missing a
partner there and that we were only
expressing PBR one and a TRP PHP and we
were kind of missing that PBS one
homologue when we were putting it into
this other plant where we're trying to
rebuild the response we think that the
reason we didn't have to put in another
PBS one during that interaction is
because these kinases are conserved in
all flowering plants so Nicole Sean of
Indiana has a PBS one homologue and that
is also able to be cleaved by a TRP PHP
so it's possible that PBR one is a bit
of a promiscuous protein and can
associate with TBS one homologs from
different plants and that'll allow it to
mediate the response and detect a TRP
PHP activity but we're still kind of
left with that question because we
didn't have to do that when we were
rebuilding this response to a different
plant so to answer the question of how
PBR 1 and PBS 1 relate to each other
with this system we decided to do a
co-immunoprecipitation assay and we're
just gonna focus on the right half of
this slide and just on a few boxes that
I'm gonna
line for you basically how this works is
we are trying to pull down PBR one see
and see what comes with it and therefore
what was associating with it in planta
the blue box with black bars is
indicating that we were successfully
pulling down PBR one seat and when we
did so the PBS one homologs from arab
adopts Asst barley and a co Siana were
all able to come down with PBR one see
so we could get this association that
PBR 1 and PDS one homologs are forming
in planta this is specific to PBR one I
was not just the result of some kind of
cell membrane thing because we had a
negative control that was also plasma
membrane localizing so that allows us to
finish our model and we can see that PBR
1 does appear to associate PBS 1 and
planta so it's likely mediating the
interaction by detecting when PBS 1 is
being cleaved by a TRP PHP and if we go
back to looking at the Arab adopts this
mechanism that we had for detecting a br
P bhp and this new barley mechanism that
we've characterized they do seem very
similar and this is convergent evolution
of analogous resistant mechanisms
because PB r 1 and r ps5 are not direct
orthologues and they evolved
independently to serve the same role of
kinase carding to detect against
effectors that are trying to shut down
PTI so bringing that back to kind of
what next in the larger picture if this
PBS one guarded mechanism is present in
barley and a rabbit Oxus it's highly
likely it is present in other flowering
plants we know from our own evidence
that wheat has a homologue a PBR one and
my co first author Matt Helm found did
more work to determine that PBS 1 and
soybean can be engineered for viral
immunity and the future application of
this as kind of a reminder is that you
can increase disease resistance in
barley and other crops by deploying
engineered decoys based on prettiest
effectors with known cleavage sites so
you can create these different PDFs one
decoys and put them back in your plant
of intro
to create new kinds of pathogen
resistance now I need everybody to also
take a breath for a second because I'm
going to leave this lovely story and a
plant behind and we're going to think
about something totally different
because I had been working so much in
bacteria that infect plants and thinking
about plant resistance mechanisms and
how to effector proteins work and
everything in this very specific
environment I kind of got a little bit
interested in thinking about what
happens if a bacterium lives inside of a
fungus instead especially because we are
learning more and more as more studies
are coming out that many fungi harbor
bacteria inside of them we really don't
know anything about how these
interactions are formed and whether or
not they use effector proteins and
things like that it's a very active
emerging area of research so for my
final chapter I started thinking about
what if you live in a fungus and the
fungus that I'm interested in is rice
this makers force it infects rice
seedlings and immunocompromised humans
it's also a temp a fermenter a bread
mold and a soil saprophyte so it's kind
of a jack-of-all-trades fungus some
isolates of rice because my curse forest
harbor endosymbiotic Berkeley area
species which are shown in this
micrograph they are glowing green in the
top left image you can see green
bacteria in a fungal hypha and in the
top right image there's a bacterium and
a sport other non host rhizopus isolates
interact antagonistically with pirkled
areas it's very interesting system for
looking at what's required to establish
a maintain a symbiosis and whether or
not you can lose that this clade of
burkewood area bacteria was recently
restructured into a new genus called my
sido habit ins but i'm gonna refer to it
just as pirkled area for this
presentation for ease of communication
so what do we know about the Brooklyn
area Rises the symbiosis
well the bacteria was initially
discovered in 2005 because it provides a
toxin that's necessary for plant
infection the cured fungus can no longer
kill rice seedlings it's not as clear if
bacterial present
animal infection we do know that host
sporulation requires the bacterial
partner both sexual and asexual so it
seems like the bacterium has taken hold
of its fungal host and said you're not
reproducing unless you take me with you
and this implies some about a
coevolution which is also implied by the
fact that the Brooklyn area species have
partially reduced genomes of about three
mega bases they have type 2 and type 3
secretion systems that are both required
for the symbiosis and if you knock
either one out you cannot form that
symbiosis and this micrograph is
actually showing you bacteria trying to
infect the fungal hyphae by dumping
chitin aces out of their type 2
secretion system that'll eat up enough
of the cell wall for them to kind of
melt into the cell so we know that the
type 2 secretion system is dumping
chitin aces but what is the type 3
secretion system doing well there are no
known effector proteins from this or any
other bacterial symbionts of fungi but
when the genome came out for this
specific bacterium the type strain
Berkeley rise like Seneca a few people
looked at it and went is that a tell
effector now to have that thought you
need to know what a towel effector is
towel stands for transcription activator
like effector and these are proteins
produced by Xanthomonas and while
stoniest species that are plant
pathogens so in this slide I'm showing
you a Xanthomonas bacterium infecting a
rice cell and this is actually the model
patho system that's most studied and of
ogden off lab and is kind of the way
that we were introduced to this this
whole project tell effectors have a type
3 secretion system signal so they're
able to be secreted into the plant cell
where they use nuclear localization
signals to move into the nucleus there
they can bind DNA with a repetitive DNA
recognition domain and induced
transcription be in an activation domain
of whatever they're kind of bound in
front of the idea for the bacterium is
that these tell effectors will turn on
susceptibility genes or s genes and
these are plant genes that and for some
reason making
better for bacterial infection so the
bacterium is actually trying to turn
them on and this could be some kinds of
transporters that make it more aqueous
environment or get nutrients out to the
bacterium it's a very active area of
study because of its impact on plant
resistance tala factors have also gained
a lot of interest from their use of
biotechnology their repetitive bite that
repetitive central domain that interacts
with the DNA is very modular and that
each repeat binds to a single nucleotide
each repeat is very well conserved
except for two amino acids that form the
repeat variable dye residue and those
two amino acids are actually indicate
the specificity of that repeat for which
DNA nucleotide it will bind to and we
know the code so you can take the amino
acid sequence of a tile effector and
know what DNA sequence you will expect
it to bind to based on its are V DS
conversely you can target any DNA
sequence of interest by building your
own tile effector basically like Legos
to target that DNA sequence based on the
towel R VDS that you put into your
designer towel effector and this has
been used largely in gene editing and
genetic engineering as well as you can
use it as just a designer transcription
factor when the Brooklyn area genome
came out it was right at kind of the
heyday of biotech use for towel
effectors so their first two papers that
started looking at whether or not these
endo fungal symbiotic had pal effectors
we're only looking at them from really a
biotech perspective and whether or not
they could bind DNA and whether you
could use them to make nucleases and
things but I'm much more interested in
this from a like native role of those
proteins what are they really doing in
this symbiosis we're calling them
berkland area towel lake proteins or
beetles because they don't look exactly
like Xanthomonas towels they have some
key differences first they have a
cryptic type 3 secretion signal so it
wasn't necessarily even clear off the
bat if they were effector proteins at
all they may not even be secreted
have no predicted nuclear localization
signal despite the fact that they can
bind DNA their repeat recognition domain
it has much higher variability even
though there are clear are VDS and they
do follow the tail code for how they
bind DNA and they have no activation
domain so it's very unclear as to what
they do once they bind DNA this becomes
a big old hypothesis slide and is what
I'll keep coming back to you in this
section of the talk as we dive through
each of these kind of components of the
beatle protein are they expressed during
the samosas are they secreted where do
they go and what did they do first off
we needed to pick a strain to work with
so there were three sequenced Rice's
associated Berkeley area strains when we
started off and one of these b13
actually only has one beetle gene
whereas the other two have three so we
decided to stay working with b13 and the
beetle gene that we named Beetle 1913 to
reduce the potential for redundancy to
determine whether or not beetle genes
are being expressed we are I designed a
construct that had beetle 19:13 driven
by its native promoter and tagged with M
cherry this will allow the bacteria to
fluoresce red or pink when they're
expressing Beetle 1913 they will also
always show up as yellow or green
because a constitutive yfp that's in the
same plasmid and when i reinfected rise
abyss with bacteria carrying this
plasmid and looked inside of a rice this
Haifa which is the nucleotide nuclei of
are stained and blue with Dappy for your
reference I found bacteria that we're
showing up quite bright green as well as
bright pink so it does look like Beetle
1913 is expressed in delightfully so
this made me feel like alright these are
probably not just pseudogenes they're
not just remnants are weirdly broken in
this bacterium they must be doing
something but what are they acting on
are they important for the bacterium or
are they important for the host and to
determine
I needed to figure out if they were
secreted now for the next couple things
I'm going to talk about we're actually
not doing the work inside of the rise of
his per quod area system because of the
difficulty in working in that system and
we're going to move to using
heterologous systems to be able to probe
apart these these proteins so we're
returning to our friend Pseudomonas
syringae and the model plant Miko Shawn
of Indiana to do a sigh a si the way
this works is that the catalytic domain
of adenylate cyclase which we're calling
saya is tagged on to the end of the
protein that you want to see if it's an
effector that protein fusion is then
given to Pseudomonas which is
infiltrated into your model plant and if
the Tsai a is secreted into the plant
cell it's able to convert ATP into
cyclic A&P that can be detected by Eliza
so the amount of cyclic AMP e you are
detecting is an indirect measurement of
how much secretion you got of your
protein of interest our positive control
is a vr pto and the negative control is
a type 3 secretion system mutant that's
no longer able to secrete this just
normal Pseudomonas effector our beetle
protein showed the same pattern as a bee
or pto and was able to be secreted when
the type 3 secretion system was in tact
as is evidenced by that blue bar however
this relied on the first 45 amino acids
if we chopped off the first 45 amino
acids which we had predicted was where
the secretion signal was then you no
longer get detectable cyclic a and P so
it doesn't appear that Beetle 1913 is
being secreted and if you take that just
that first 45 amino acid and try to tag
that on to sy a look for secretion you
do find a detectable cyclic AMP e levels
so it appears that the first 45 amino
acids are both necessary and sufficient
for secretion of Beetle 1913 this was
not just an artifact of protein
stability we checked by Western blot
that this was that all the proteins were
stable and this is really a secretion
output now moving back to our hypothesis
slide we can say that these proteins do
transit the type 3 secretion system so
they're being spit out in
to the fungal cell but what are they
doing when they're there while they bind
to DNA we are not sure if they go to the
nucleus because they did not have a very
clear computationally predictable
nuclear localization signal to test
where they go subcellular li i decided
to express them in yeast so my positive
control in this assay is Talon C which
is the Xanthomonas tell effector that
will nuclear localize that I've tagged
with the floor for egfp so that top row
the gfp signal is overlapping with nuke
blue DNA stain and so that indicates
that tau 1 c is going to the fungal
nucleus this is in contrast to free gfp
which is in the second row that just
kind of floats all around the e cell and
it's not specific to the nuclei in the
third row I've taken a truncated beetle
protein and tagged it with egfp and it
looks the same as ours and notice now
effector and then it does appear to
overlap with the DNA stain and it looks
like Pinot 1913 is able to nuclear
localize if I mutate an RI RK motif in
the C terminus to alanines I lost
nuclear localization and it looked more
like diffuse egfp so I believe that the
ri RK motif in the C terminus is the
nuclear localization signal now on this
slide I was only using a truncated
beetle protein because when I tried to
express the full length one I did not
get any fluorescent East cells which I
think means it's toxic this was further
verified by the fact that if I tried a
nuclear localization signal mutant of
the full-length protein so if I did the
same alanine mutant in the full-length
protein I could get fluorescent yeast
cells but it was diffused throughout the
cell so I think the fact that a fully
butyl 19:13 appeared to be cytotoxic
well an nls mutant was not just
underscores or just supports our
hypothesis that be 19:13 is functioning
in the nucleus so it makes it to the
nucleus we know it binds DNA but what's
it doing once it get there how is it
directly affecting or is it directly
affecting post transcription
to answer this question we're going back
into the plant to do a gust activity
assay which is pretty common for towel
effectors to see if promoters are up
regulated by effectors and in this case
we're taking a minimal promoter and
putting that in front of our dust gene
that will measure the activity of as a
indicator of whether or not our
telephone is up regulating Guus
expression the minimum promoter has an
ABR bs3 binding element which is
actually a tile effector that naturally
targets this promoter and that serves as
a positive control that both of our
constructs are working because we're
going to have two constructs one of
which has the beetle 19:13 binding
element and one of which has a scrambled
binding element that should not be bound
by butyl 19:13 so if it's an activator
you'd expect expect only the top
construct to go up and the other one
should just stay flat I also included a
positive control of a designer towel
effector DT 1913 which as the name
suggests is just a mimic of Beetle 1913
but in kind of a Xanthomonas towel
format so this gives us an idea of what
would happen if a Xanthomonas towel
effector was targeting the same binding
element when i looked at the relative
Guus activity all of my controls acted
normally including a negative control of
tau NC that does not target this
promoter in any way but unfortunately
Beetle 1913 looked more like our
negative control than anything else and
it did not appear that it was able to up
regulate Gus activity in planta this is
not entirely unsurprising as it did not
have an activation domain so I then
moved to the hypothesis that butene 13
is a repressor instead of an activator
to test that I just picked one way of
being a repressor although there are a
lot of different options and I was just
going to look at binding competition so
that could be nearby where I co express
a BRB s3 and butyl 19:13 that have
closed but not overlapping binding
elements or americo express butyl 1913
and DT 1913 that are in direct
competition for the same binding element
again I did not see any support for the
idea that butyl 1913 was affecting Gus
activity it did not appear to
down-regulate Gus activity in planta in
this essay as well so that left me with
the big old question mark for how the
host transcription was even being
affected by butyl 1913 and what it's
doing once it gets into the nucleus and
binds DNA and this will have to be the
subject of future study and we're still
kind of leaving it as is right now so
what are they doing it does look like
there are effectors but what impact do
they have on the host of symbiosis and
to answer that we need to look in the
native system
and we need to move into phenotyping and
looking at transcriptome analysis so we
find that when we made a beetle 19:13
unit it seemed pretty fine so we were
able to make him you know it grew fine
it was able to still infect the fungus
and fungi infected with wild type or
mutant bacterium we're still able to
grow well on nutrient rich media they
were still able to sporulate
equivalently both asexually as well as
mate and form sexual spores so I moved
into trying to stress the fungus out to
see if I could get at something that
would show me a phenotype and I plated
fungi infected with wild type or mutant
bacteria on nutrient poor media media
with salt stress and media with
oxidative stress to look for any kind of
difference in growth but still did not
find any however when I plated fungi
infected with the butyl 1913 mutant on
media amended with sodium dodecyl
sulfate or SDS I did find a reduction in
growth SDS is a detergent that causes
cell membrane stress so it appears that
the butyl 1913 mutant increased the host
susceptibility to SDS this is a
macroscopic phenotype and I wanted to
get at the molecular underpinnings of it
by looking to see if there are any kinds
of transcriptional or gene expression
changes that would let us understand
what was going on to cause this
difference in growth however when I did
RNA seek on wild-type mutant and
complement infected rhizopus I
only found 15 jeans that were shared as
either up or downregulated in the wild
type and the compliment versus the
mutant and when I looked at the gene
description of those jeans I found a lot
of hypotheticals and unknown functions I
also found that most of them had
predicted binding elements for butyl
1913 so none of this really gave me an
obvious target or mechanism for how
butyl 1913 was causing this difference
in growth and this is just kind of a
lesson and that your RNA seek is pretty
much as useful as the functional gene
annotation of the organism you're
working in now all of the work so far
had been done just focusing on beetle
1913 and strain b13 but we were also
thinking a bit broader and I wanted to
know if what we had found in this system
would apply to other strains and species
of prices associated brooklet area as
well so we did a global analysis of
risings associated burkewood area
streams and look to see if they had
eatle genes by southern blot so black
bands in this blot on the right are
indicating that there are beetle genes
present across rasmus associated
Brookwood area streams although they
vary a number as well as probably
genomic context by the fact that the
bands are kind of all over the place
thinking ahead to whether or not beetle
genes were serving the same role in the
symbiosis or whether they differentiated
and function I decided to take one of
the beetle genes that we knew the
sequence of and clone it out from
bacterial strain b14 and see if I could
rescue my Beetle 1913 mutant phenotype
with this beetle 1814 gene so taking one
from a different strain putting it into
the mutant of my strain and seeing if
that does anything in terms of the
phenotype I was seeing and it did not so
it's not exactly unexpected that a
different beetle from a different strain
did not rescue my beetle mutant because
RVD sequences of these talaq proteins do
look different so they are likely
binding different DNA
so the conclusions from this part or
that despite the cryptic nature or lack
of typical tall domains urban supports
the hypothesis that beetle proteins are
secreted nuclear localizing effectors
that impact the host fungus this is the
first characterized defector from dis
samosas in the first towel leg protein
that is targeting a fungal host you know
19:13 does affect rise this microspores
in some way that makes it less
susceptible to SDS exposure a cell
membrane stress although we don't really
know the biological relevance of that at
this point and there's a lot to discover
about the functional diversity of beetle
proteins as beetle
18:14 can't rescue beetle 19:13 so the
questions remaining are vast but include
what is the effect of SDS stress or cell
membrane stress on fungi and how does
that affect the partnership is this
actually something about how the fungus
is interacting with his environment that
is a benefit the bacterium is conferring
or is it something about how the
bacterium is restructuring the fungus to
make it a better home for the bacteria
what's the actual target of beetle 19:13
and how does it cause transcriptional
changes is it relying on endogenous host
proteins that were not present in the
assays we tested or other effector
proteins or is it working by some
repression mechanism that we have not
tested yet what does this tell us about
Tala factor evolution or effector
evolution in general and how bacteria
that live inside of different kinds of
hosts and in different kinds of
interactions use the same types of
effectors but possibly in different ways
and then do beetles within our across
strains have different functions have
they diversified and what they're doing
within the symbiosis or do they act as
host specificity factors and it's just
that they're targeting polymorphic sites
in the fungal genome so I'm done telling
you all of my stories and I just wanted
to bring you back to the title of my
thesis which again was translating
lessons from effector biology to all
these different subjects and bringing it
back to what I was able to do with
fungal effector screens I was able to
use bacterial delivery to probe the role
of individual effectors I was able to
take a look at plant resistance
mechanisms that we already knew about in
model systems
then identify engineer will disease
resistance mechanisms in crop plants and
finally the taking what we know about
towel effectors from plant pathogenic
fungi or bacteria I was able to look at
bacteria that interact with a fungal
host and learn about how they can
manipulate a fungal host and about
effector evolution so at that I'd like
to acknowledge that the fungal effector
project and barley project were largely
done in collaboration with Roger Ennis
and Roger Rice's labs I've had two
amazing amazing undergraduate assistants
on that project that were both authors
on that barley and PMI paper and Matt
Helm was an excellent co first author
and he's continuing the decoy
engineering work during his postdoc so I
highly recommend you check out his work
and follow him if you're interested in
that the beetle project was done largely
in-house here at Cornell with a lot of
help from different people from Teresa
and Adams lab based on their various
expertise formal acknowledgements of
funding I especially wanted to note that
I was on a USDA predock fellowship for
this last chapter which allowed me to be
a lot more independent and was a great
excuse to do a whole grant while I was
still in grad school so I highly
recommend that to any students who are
near candidacy the deadline this year is
in August I also wanted to thank the
University of Minnesota for the barley
Anam population publication as well as a
variety of people at Cornell who helped
with a lot of guidance and resources and
all kinds of things and just quickly I
have been really blessed with my time
here at Cornell to have had to be an
awesome launching point from being
involved in just the community here
through the chili cook-off and the GSA
to getting to go to conferences like em
PMI and APs and Triple A s with friends
and colleagues and being able to network
and share my research and learn I've
also gotten really involved in science
policy through a lot of support from
Cornell and ApS and I was thankful to
get to go to India with the Cornell
Alliance for science so granel's been a
phenomenal place full of opportunities
for me
I have to thank my lab and if I could go
back and do it all again I would pick
the Bogdanov lab a hundred times out of
a hundred because it's like a lovely
group of very supportive fun smart
fascinating people submit an awesome
international community to hang out with
and meet people from all over and I just
really appreciated their uplifting
spirits and humor over the years as well
as all the amazing food and our silly
coffee breaks and things I am also very
chatty and tend to need people to talk
to so I was very blessed to come in with
a wonderfully amazing cohort especially
the women I came in with who really
supported each other and build each
other up through all of this and they're
all in awesome places now and I've
really appreciated their support
throughout the process as well as tons
of conference friends lab mates and
game-night buds so it's just been a wild
ride and I've met an amazing community
of people I have to especially thank my
husband he will be defending his PhD in
physics becoming dr. Alex money this
summer and doing grad school with
another person as difficulty but it also
makes it a lot easier and I'm so
thankful for all of his support
especially and that he has listened to
me to give this talk about 20 times
because we're stuck working at home with
side-by-side desks so special shout out
to him so at that I will take any
questions and I wanted to thank everyone
who joined this virtual seminar and
helped make it special and was so fun to
watch everybody's names pop up at the
beginning so you can ask questions in
the chat or if you go to the
participants menu there's an option to
kind of raise your hand and we'll try to
call on you and make this happen
so anybody who wants to unmute
themselves and give in join me in
congratulating Morgan and thank you for
a great talk please do so
absolutely amazing
great job Morgan so Morgan I've agreed
that she will moderate she'll field the
questions with this format it's probably
gonna be easier easy enough for her just
to see who's raising a hand I see John
has his hand up Morgan you can start
there yeah let's start with John I'm
Morgan that was terrific I do have a
question though about the competition
experiment I mean I think the pursuing
just how Beatles 1913 does its thing
influences the genome is fascinating
you're you did a pretty stringent test
for a competition where you asked beetle
1913 to compete with another towel
effector and I'm wondering do you know
what the relative binding constants are
for those two different towel effectors
for the target and and as was it a fair
test
yeah that's a good question I do not
know if it was a fair test I we did find
the I think the binding concept for the
beetle protein when we were initially
just seeing if it would find that
element before he introduced it into our
assay but we did not test the affinity
of the designer towel effector so it's
possible that the designer towel
effector was just a better binder and
was out competing and it wasn't really
dependent on activation at that point
yeah so so I mean I think it you could
still think about interfering with
functions of other DNA binding proteins
and and and it's so that that mechanism
could still be viable and probably very
interesting if it turns out to be so but
I could also envision that it that
although it has no activation domain and
then it doesn't have the standard towel
activation domain
it could still possibly be acting
positively if for instance it were
helping open opening up nucleosomes
open young well yeah opening chromatin
or opening DNA in general and
facilitating other factors to bind and
I'm wondering if if you have any
thoughts about that yeah I think these
are all good points and it just shows
the limits of what we tested in terms of
activation and repression
because we were kind of focused on our
hypotheses being grounded whether or not
this was acting like a tell effector so
we were testing to see if this kind of
does the same things as tell effectors
and after that it's a much bigger
question about what it's doing if it's
not doing that right it looks like it's
not doing exactly what a tell effector
does in a plant but after that yeah it
could still be an activator it has kind
of acidic patches on its outside who
knows if those are interacting with host
proteins that we just aren't that
weren't present and what we were doing
so I think it's a really cool area that
could be a whole nother paper is just
figuring out what it's doing once it
binds DNA yeah um so the next question I
saw was from Alvaro hi Morgan awesome
presentation really like an insane
amount of work thank you so I do have to
ask about the process following up on
the function I guess you've seen the
prepend the recently penned by rick
turtle where they suggest a function for
the stella factors in protecting the
bacteria from fungal entrapment what do
you think about that hypothesis death is
there any discrepancies with your work
in theirs yeah so al burrows discussing
the fact that a preprint was posted
about three weeks after ours that was
using a different strain of bacteria
that are in crisis and they did their
own Beatle mutant and found a phenotype
where it was inhibiting sporulation of
the fungus and that beetles are
important for basically establishing of
the symbiosis we've thoroughly verified
our mutants and we did not see the same
phenotype so if there's
is verified then it must be that they're
doing different things in different
strains we have not really investigated
that strain in terms of making a mutant
but it is a very difficult system to
work in so I think we all have to be
careful with what we're what we're
seeing and whether things are replicable
and can complement so that's what we
focus a lot on in our study so I'll be
interested to see how much their stuff
compliments but they have incredibly
amazing micrograph images in that paper
that I swoon over so I am really excited
to see what comes out of their work as
they keep focusing on this um ok so the
next question I saw was from Matthew
Ullman hi I'm Morgan you did a really
awesome job I have a question about your
barley project it looked like you said
you had two versions of the barley PBS
one and you had your inter at your Co IP
experiment with PBR one it looked like
both of your PBS ones were highly
expressed in your we're highly present
in your experiment but it looked like
one was more highly interacting with PBR
one in a gel that you showed anyway do
you always see that and you can can you
do you have a prediction for why one was
interacting more than the other
Matt's plot I think that was a common
thing that we saw but it wasn't entirely
consistent because
phylogenetically one of these barley PBS
ones is closer related than the other
one to the arab adaxes PBS one it could
be that like how they're associating is
slightly dependent on some kind of
sequence variation that we weren't
really focused on because we were
looking at the ATR pph be part and we do
know that certain parts of like PBS one
are involved in interaction with Arab
adopts this RPS five but we don't know
as much about what's involved in the PBR
one interaction so I think that that's
one of the things that Matt is following
up on in his postdoc work is looking
into what more about how PD r1 and PBS
one can interact and which domains are
involved in that and the specificity
cool thank you yeah
so the next question I actually saw was
on the chat and this was from Marina and
she asked if we know how beetle goes
inside the nucleus and if it's possible
it's using fungal proteins to be
imported into the nucleus and whether or
not we've done any Co IP with fungal
proteins so I have not done any Co IP or
anything in the native system with
beetle proteins and trying to pull them
out and look about what's coming with
them in terms of protein interaction or
DNA interaction I think that's a really
interesting Avenue to go down in the
future but we cannot over express these
proteins in the natural fungus rise bus
because you can't really transform rise
of this right now so that's something
that could be done in in yeast
potentially to try to look for
interactors I don't personally know
exactly the nuclear import pathway
anymore I think I've learned that at one
point but I do know that the beetle
nuclear localization signal well very
cryptic and doesn't really correspond to
like an it isn't often computationally
predicted it does resemble like a small
part of what some of the towel effector
nuclear important signals
like so I think it's probably the same
as how all effectors get into plants it
kind of just your average nuclear import
system so the next question is from me
let's limit it to the next two I don't
think they're any more after that but
yeah break before you start the second
part of your defense yeah so Daniel was
the next question and we're gonna dance
weenie a really nice job I had a
question about the barley not surprising
so my Molecular Plant Pathology is a
little bit rusty but thinking
practically about how you would
potentially engineer resistance to
sweets of pathogens do you think it
would mostly be limited to bio Trump's
with the system since your would be
inducing a hypersensitive response or
could have potentially a little more
broad than that um
my gut reaction says probably limiting
to bio troops but I guess it just
depends a lot on I mean yeah probably
not your average neck or if that's just
coming in and trying to blast everything
but I think it'll be interesting to see
which bio tropes we want to limit it to
as well because you want to focus on
ones that the produces are rather
important because you don't want to put
in all the work to make a plant that
you've engineered that then the pathogen
can just drop the protease super easily
so I think that's where this research
has to go next in figuring out like what
the best way to deploy it is and that's
why there's been a lot of focus on
viruses because the Priuses and viruses
are so critical to their lifestyle that
it would be hard for them to just drop
that or change what they target okay and
then Bill's the last question cool
hey Morgan I'm super super great
presentation mine is sort of in that
same vein of barley topics as well and
on the powdery mildew side probably not
surprisingly as kind of a being on the
front lines of you know thinking about
effectors and I will get by Oh terrific
pathogens such as powdery mildews
from your experiences do you think we're
still a ways away from being able to
look for like putative forms of
resistance from like the effector
perspective in the fungus and largely
have to focus kind of from the host and
looking for resistance genes in the host
which it seems like you know you took
that route I'm just kind of curious
about bigger picture where you think
that field stands for obligate bio
tropes going forward yeah so one of the
reasons we actually got into this is
because the the effector we were using
and looking at the most with trying to
develop the screens with the bacteria
was a protease from powdery mildew
expect 10:19 anyway so that protein um
and the idea was like well if you can
figure out what this produce is
targeting especially because it seemed
like that produce was very conserved
across a lot of plant pathogenic fungi
that maybe it could be a way to take
like actual powdery mildew effector
biology and apply it into plant like
engineering plant resistance instead of
just looking for resistance genes that
already occur so I think we're on the
cusp of being able to make that happen
especially as there are better ways to
characterize effectors from like mildews
and rust because that's been just such a
pipeline backlog right now and I think
unfortunately the reason that I didn't
follow up on that as much as because by
the time he got that screen sorted out
it was just you know you could screen
infinite lines of barley looking for you
know different resistances across so
it's a lot of work and it's a really
good thing to like start on a project
early on is doing a big just you know
fishing expedition for what resistance
can we find it's already interacting
with barley but I ended up focusing more
on like well how can we engineer a plant
based on what we know about like a
barley protease or a powdery mildew
protease so that was kind of in the
middle ground of that I guess okay
that's it thanks again everybody
especially as you sort of bore with us
when we're trying to figure out the ins
and outs is hosting a seminar with zoom
we've got a little bit of a late start
because of that and I appreciate
everybody staying on to the very end
here and thanks again Morgan take a
little break we'll see in a few minutes
with your committee okay thank you
everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu